the following video was made during the
wga and sag-aftra Strikes this channel
fully supports those unions and this
video is a work of critique analysis or
review which is allowable under the
guidelines those unions have put forward
for those wishing to support them any
praise offered is intended to be praised
for the writers actors and other
creators who make the work and not for
the studio that produced it
oh angel
what have you done
[Music]
so despite not jumping on it immediately
as pretty much everybody did I have now
seen good Omens two and I do have
thoughts to share I debated whether or
not to put this up here or do this as a
review in the break room however this is
a review with a particular slant and
it's a slant that I've done before and
when I have
it's been here in the main Channel and
so here we are
much like Neil Gaiman Sandman before it
good Omens too is not only a masterful
adaptation like Sandman was but in
addition to that it's not even really an
adaptation but it also super is
and Gaiman avoids
so many pitfalls of this kind of
follow-up series especially on something
that was super popular and I will make
some direct comparisons to give you an
idea of uh what I'm comparing this to
and contrasting it against
short version
this is
very good
the performances naturally are spot on
terrific Jon Hamm while he is
exceptionally good at the very very
handsome dumbass he doesn't always work
for me or at least he tends to work in
very limited doses this is probably
where he's gone down the best for me
when he's done this aspect of what he's
able to bring uh to a part
and again that's not me saying that I
don't like him in other places it's just
very rare that I get excited about his
presence but he's utilized incredibly
well here of course uh David Tennant
Michael Sheen completely nailing
literally everything
every single bit I love that we get the
Metatron back and we get some more of
Derek Jacoby and that part I like that
they brought back some actors in
different parts like Miranda Richardson
playing Shacks Nina sosanya and Maggie
service in new roles named Nina and
Maggie that seems like an open
acknowledgment that these parts were
written for them which might seem odd
since I call this an adaptation how
could these parts have been written for
them if this is an adaptation of
existing work well it sort of is
and it sort of isn't
so this is not going to be a breakdown
of everything that goes on in season two
nor is it going to be me cataloging
absolutely everything I liked or
anything that I thought didn't work the
short version is there wasn't really
that much that I thought didn't work
there was one thing that like isn't my
favorite thing in the world and that is
kind of the uh approach to the romance
angle between Nina and Maggie just it
felt a little contrived little trophy
but that having been said it was
probably the least offensive version
I've seen of that kind of Trope of oh we
need to get these two people to fall in
love for reasons unrelated to the idea
that they would be in love and I don't
like that as a plot device but you know
it's done with a delicate touch it's
done without completely diving into all
the associated aspects tropes and
cliches that I don't like about that
kind of story and it even gets called
out at the end when Nina saying flat out
my relationship just ended I am not
ready to start another one yet
I'll just be a rebound mess so I like
that it also gets called out as that was
a bad idea so
uh it's it's a it's a Trope I don't like
handled about as well as I ever expected
to be handled at least to my taste as
someone who doesn't like it the
development of the relationships between
characters is wonderfully handled the
pacing is great it is scaled just right
and talking about the scale and scope of
it
that's going to lead into what I mean
when I say that this is a masterful
adaptation
so here were the concerns coming in to
the second season the first season of
good Omens has a completed novel upon
which to be based written by the late
Terry Pratchett and Neil Gaiman and Neil
Gaiman headed up that show to ensure
that it would be honored and would
result in something that Terry Pratchett
would have been proud of Terry Pratchett
his personal friend who sadly is no
longer with us and I don't think there's
a lot of belief that he didn't pretty
much nail that it's got nearly
everything that you would want from the
book plus a new additions and expansions
with characters like Gabriel but for the
most part it is an adaptation that is
incredibly true to the source of
material while doing a fantastic job of
bringing to life everything that you
want while also presenting it in a way
that is just different enough that it
doesn't just feel like well they just
they just took the book and just did
that which I I know is a complaint uh
not everyone has but it's one that I
tend to have
I I get
frustrated with overly loyal adaptations
because if it's exactly like the source
material my first instinct is I should
just read the source material again then
um so whether or not that's an issue
depends how familiar I am with the
source material and I am with good Omens
so that was the first season
I was very skeptical about the notion of
a second season not just because there
wasn't a completed piece of work for it
to be based off of there wasn't as solid
a foundation at least not that we knew
how it was and what condition it was in
but also Gaiman seemed iffy about coming
back and show running especially because
he was now working with Sandman as well
so when it was announced and Gaiman laid
out that okay you know there were a
whole bunch of notes and a outline for a
story that Terry and I had that we were
going to consider as a follow-up and
there is something to work it off that
still has Terry pratchett's ideas
Notions instincts and story beats so I
thought okay that's
that's not nothing so they're not
creating it out of nowhere without one
of the major creators of the original
work no longer around to contribute uh
they are basing it off some things that
he had that still felt like a dicey
proposition even with Gaiman saying he
would uh still be involved fairly
directly
then came the interesting hitch
Gaiman confirmed ahead of this season's
release that despite the fact that there
is basically the bones and outline of
what was going to be a second book
that's not the basis of this season
that would be the basis of a theoretical
third season but Gaiman was of the
opinion that from where things ended
with the first season to where the story
he and Terry Pratchett outlines would
pick up
in a television format it wasn't going
to work jumping from one to the other he
needed to find another story that he
could tell in the interim that while not
strictly being nothing but set up would
lay the groundwork for where things
needed to be to tell the story that he
and Terry Pratchett laid out
so what we have here
is less of an adaptation and more of a
made for the screen sequel
but I'm still going to consider an
adaptation because it had to make a lot
of adaptation related choices
and that is going to be yes in many ways
influenced by stuff that we as the
audience do not know about and won't
unless a third season happens and we get
to see what the actual story uh was and
how much of the groundwork was laid
obviously the way that the season ends
uh if you hadn't guessed already
spoilers are gonna be flying pretty
freely
um well the way the season ends very
much feels like this is a different
situation for any future story to pick
up on but other than that there might be
other things that was groundwork being
late that we just aren't aware of and we
won't know until later but it's no small
thing
to continue stories for characters past
the story they were designed to tell
and that is what makes this an
incredibly smart second season as well
as a smart adaptation because as an
adaptation it does pick up some
lingering threads from the initial one
uh not even lingering threads but just
elements that it could play with such as
what we ended up getting with the Nazi
zombies those are something picking up
directly from the first season not
something I was expecting to happen but
it has its ties and it makes sense to
include them and of course there's the
continuing relationship between Crowley
and azaraphan and the way that that
is altered and changed by the
circumstances that they're in right now
when Gabriel shows up with no memory of
who he is and what has happened to him
but in addition to that just not being
specifically tied to Heaven or Hell
anymore
and for where they end up by the end
it's quite
quite smart and how it builds that
because
you may not realize it on first viewing
because you don't necessarily know where
it's going
but throughout the season
there are plenty of small moments small
hints you can tell from the way he talks
about certain things just the way he
hears himself Crowley is incredibly
happy to be
cut from his ties with hell has no
interest in them doesn't miss them
didn't really like them last time either
he's happy to be a free agent just do
his own thing he's still grumpy because
that's who he is but then aziraphail
while he has officially severed ties
from Heaven you can see that lingering
sense of connection to it maybe he
misses it or at least he still believes
in the potential of good that heaven has
which culminates in some things that
happen at the very end of the season
and that groundwork is laid here and
it's groundwork that makes sense coming
off of the end of the previous season
it's a Natural Evolution that takes
characters already adapted pretty
directly from a completed work and moves
them forward in a way that feels like a
natural extension of when we last saw
them this is no small feat I have read
works that are intended as follow-ups
after
um the original establishing author is
no longer around an example that comes
to mind is the book and another thing by
Ian kofer which is a follow-up to The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy books
now I actually do rather like uh and
another thing I think it captures
Douglas Adams's voice as a writer very
well which is the main thing I really
needed it to do and it also ends on just
a nicer note than uh mostly harmless did
which is nice but you did feel those
restrictions that he seemed very
cautious and very uncertain about moving
the characters forward and shifting them
and having them go in new directions
instead it was much more about kind of
affirming who the reader knows them to
be and then giving them a different
situation in a different ending here
granted Gaiman is the co-creator but
he's always been pretty upfront that he
considered good Omens to be more
pratchetts than his which if you've read
some of gaiman's earlier work he
actually has quite a skill at adopting
The Narrative voice of other writers he
actually did it to Douglas Adams as well
when he wrote a biography about him
which is delightful and is written very
much in the style like Douglas Adams
himself would write so it makes sense to
me that a lot of the tone and pace and
way that good Omens the original novel
flows is largely down to Pratchett with
game and sort of adapting his style to
match his
so moving those things forward having
the confidence to continue a path rather
than just reaffirm yep still the same
guys still the same characters
that's bold
and he does pull it off
now as I said this isn't real
adaptation
it is a sequel though
and sequels to things that are completed
stories is really hard
especially these days
I should say it used to be easy easier
you know
30 40 more years ago because it used to
be that when you got a sequel be it a
sequel book a sequel movie a follow-up
TV series they were more rare back in
the day but anything of that nature
they tended to be treated as their own
contained entity take something like the
James Bond films or the Thin Man films
or any series of that kind of nature
where yeah there's earlier ones yeah
some recurring characters but like you
don't need to have seen an earlier one
to watch this you'll get it we're not
serializing a story here these are all
self-contained stories
that's pretty easy to do
but that's not the world we live in now
the streaming age precarious as it now
appears to be coming on the heels of the
quote-unquote golden age of television
with shows like Game of Thrones before
it went to hell Breaking Bad which
stayed good all the way through and
especially the one I'm gonna compare the
most with stranger things
there is so much more emphasis on each
season
telling a grander story
that you can't just take your finisher
like cool that was done now we're going
to do a new thing and you don't need the
old one to to have seen it but the
problem becomes and again citing
stranger things in particular
trying to balance a desire to move the
story forward while also fulfilling a
lot of the expectations of a second
season of a show one of the big ones
being well the whole cast is back right
one of the things that I believe very
thoroughly has hampered stranger things
over the years in basically to some
degree in every season other than the
first one
is that not all these characters should
still be here
and I don't mean like logistically well
I mean they're still in the town why
wouldn't they be involved no I'm not
talking narrative Logistics I'm talking
utility
so
every character who was present in the
first season of stranger things
had a reason to be there and everything
revolved around will buyer's
disappearance and everybody felt pulled
in on that everybody had some part to
play centered around this Central issue
of what happened to Will buyers
when we get to the second season and not
only are we introducing new characters
but everybody who lived through the
first one is also back
some of these characters don't have a
reason to be here anymore if you take
the actual Story the actual narrative
being told in season three season two
season four don't know why I said the
Mata border but I did I'm rolling with
it
a lot of those are gonna have characters
like there isn't a reason for you to be
here it varies from season to season
season three I really didn't see why uh
will was there I haven't understood why
Jonathan's been there for several
seasons Mike has felt incredibly superb
fluid ever since the first season it's
like the show is desperately trying to
think of something to do with him
because he was kind of the main
character or he certainly was framed as
one in that first season but like these
later stories don't need him but he's
still there and he feels Superfluous
he's a hanger on
this is a very common problem where
there is a belief that because the
audience expects everybody to come back
you bring them all back even if the
story you're telling
has no use for them at all second season
of Jessica Jones had this issue as well
particularly when it came to the lawyer
played by carrion Moss who had a purpose
in the first season and none in the
second but that's where good Omens
benefits from
some smart decisions but also
some good fortune
because if you actually go back and
think about that first season or if
you've read the book it's fairly
sprawling there's a zeraphil and Crowley
yes of course and you could say that the
Heaven and Hell material is kind of an
extension of either of them okay
but you've also got Adam and all of his
friends you have the witchfinders Army
you have this medium you have this woman
with this book of prophecies
these things all had utility and they
created a large canvas in the first
season
and the second season drops
pretty much all of them that are not a
zero felon Crowley or characters who tie
directly to either of them that's
something a lot of shows wouldn't have
done because standard studio thinking is
well if this was successful before if
we're going to do it again bring back as
many of the elements were in the first
one is possible because
wild studio uh and producer and
executive thought process is very good
at the idea that okay find the things
that work and keep doing them it's
actually very bad at identifying what
those are and it tends to uh assume that
well we should just bring in everything
we can because we're not certain which
is the thing that people really loved
and made it really successful
and
um we don't want to risk dropping the
thing or maybe it just needs all of them
together
and that's part of how you get all these
unnecessary characters still hanging
around in so many things
but not here and again I'm blaming
Studios I'm blaming Executives because
that's the mentality it may sometimes be
a choice being made by the writer showed
showrunner Etc but the mentality that
leads to that decision
keep them around even if we don't have a
reason for them to be just because
they've been here when it was successful
before is very much an executive uh
Studio or network style decision
regardless of who makes it
so good Omens as I said drops
pretty much everybody other than Crowley
and xerophil and their direct Affiliated
characters despite bringing back some of
the actors to come back and play new
ones and also recasting uh bl's above
though that wasn't a creative decision
there was a scheduling conflict they
couldn't bring back to the original
actor it happens
it's on your face
well this whole thing this is also aside
from being a very smart idea to narrow
the story because you try and tell
another story that encompasses all of
these characters again you're gonna end
up with one of two things you're going
to either end up with a story where you
can tell a bunch of them shouldn't be
there and they don't have a reason to be
there which is what I'd mentioned like
being a stranger things problem or
you're gonna end up with something that
gives them all something to do but just
feels like it's recreating the previous
one because if you give everybody a role
again then well you've created not a
follow-up but you've just recreated your
previous story even if some of the
logistics are different that doesn't
happen here either instead it zeros in
on these two cuts everybody else and
this is where the Good Fortune I
mentioned comes in
because while I do think pretty much all
the aspects of good Omens were very
strong
what everyone latched on to the fandom
especially what they loved more than
anything else
was a zero fail
and Crowley
and you could narrow it down to them and
in doing so
bring them a new Supporting Cast and
tell
a smaller story
yes arguably the consequences and the uh
potential Fallout are of a similar scale
in terms of how bad things could go
and certainly as we find out by the end
like there could have been world ending
consequences to this story but it's
never presented that way
we're not jumping between locations
we're not getting sprawling look at the
world we're keeping it very much to
these two and whatever else is going on
we're going to focus on them so we're
going smaller we're going more intimate
and we're lucky that the two characters
that it is easiest to build a continued
story around because Adam and his
friends theoretically should have an
incredibly normal and boring life
anathema Newton they should just be able
to have their happily ever after at this
point the head of the witchfinder's army
should really just be retiring
so there isn't more story to tell these
people without in some way feeling like
you're rolling back their endings
a zero film Crowley
there's more you could do there
and that's the direction they so so
smartly went I do talk about adaptation
now and then I don't zero in on it I
don't hyper focus on it uh there are
other creators who do that incredibly
well hey Dom how you doing but
this is a case where the fine points of
the ways in which it is not only an
adaptation taking an existing character
setting and world to build a new story
with but also serving as a sequel to a
story that while a sequel was planned
out that original story was not designed
to have one all of this
is so difficult
there are so many stumbling blocks in
adaptation in the first place there's so
many stumbling blocks in continuing the
story of characters who were designed to
only serve in a one-off
there are so many stumbling points for
any sequel that is intended to feel like
it is part of a Continuing Story
and this
dodges
pretty much all of them
I
continue to be
kind of in awe
of what Gaiman has been doing in
television lately
and I respected Gaiman as a writer for a
very long time
but
I really wasn't sure how smoothly he was
going to adapt to
the medium of Television a quick note
before everyone jumps something in the
comments yes I know he has written for
television before this but those were
one-off episodes this is show running
and that's what I'm referring to
he is taken to it like a fish to water
gamen is an incredibly Adept Storyteller
who
does something that is very rare
and then sort of doubles down on it the
rare thing that he does is very very
carefully tailor the story that he's
telling to the medium in which it's been
told which is so important and that's
something I have talked about numerous
times before the deepest divides into
that was talking about Zack Snyder's
Watchman if you want a frame of
reference for what I'm talking about
there
but the thing is most of the other
creators that I can think of that really
tailored their stories very carefully to
take proper advantage of the medium
they're working in
tend to not work in that many mediums
Alan Moore pretty much sticks to comic
books Terry Pratchett pretty much stuck
to novels they and numerous others are
incredibly talented and Incredibly
knowledgeable about the medium that they
have chosen to work in but they tend to
refine a Mastery of those specific few
mediums
but every now and then
you get somebody who can change mediums
and shift their approach to really truly
tailored to that you get people like the
late Douglas Adams who was able to take
the same story tell it as a radio drama
tell it as a novel tell it as a video
game and also did his time in television
working on Doctor Who and did that
really well too
and similarly there's Neil Gaiman
his Sandman and the way it is told is
tailored to comic books very very well
his novels are tailored to the written
word end to prose I think Stardust is an
excellent example of that looking at the
differences basically boils down to we
had to change the things that you can
totally get away with in a book and you
cannot get away within a movie
because the original work was very
tailored to what he wrote in and now
he's proving himself very very good at
tailoring his work
to the TV format although this was mini
series might be more appropriate six
episodes per season the second season
literally called good Omens two it
wasn't guaranteed I don't know but it's
the television format these are not easy
jumps to make especially revisiting a
story that you've already done elsewhere
but between this and Sandman Gaiman is
proving
incredible at it and I am
fascinated watching him account for
things that I see fail to be accounted
for over and over and over again either
by the people adapting or work from
another medium or by people who have
already told the story one way and are
trying to tell it the same way again in
a different format and it's not going to
work
he seems to understand this
now does this mean he'll never screw up
no
in an idealized World once the strikes
are over and both actors and writers are
paid fairly for their work and their
labor
and hopefully we have less massively
overpaid CEOs but that's me really
getting wishful
but at some point we will hopefully
get a second season of Sandman and we
will get a third season of good Omens
and he will continue to prove his skill
might one or the other of those be a
stumbled be scruple
yeah man's human not everything he's
written is perfect
but his work is not easy to deal with
you can look at the eventual falling
down on its face of the American Gods
series that started out so well it was
such a good adaptation and then it just
went to heck and a big part of why it
went to heck was because it deviated and
went in some odd directions and kept
characters around way past their utility
sorry to spoil American Gods but Mr
Wednesday who was played by Ian McShane
in that series he dies pretty early into
the book and it's pretty vital that he
does but he is just hanging around
season after season on that show because
he was popular he was kept around for no
reason other than well he's a popular
aspect we can't get rid of him yet even
though the story demands that he die
these are the things Gaiman seems to
really have an awareness of and is
incredibly good at taking into account
and adjusting for
and it makes me
far less nervous than I probably would
be under most other circumstances when
it comes to what will he do
with another season of Sandman with
another season of good Omens
I
am fascinated by how he is adapting his
works and I really hope that we get to
see more
what did you think about good Omens two
did you like it as much as I did because
I
liked it a lot I know I focused on the
adaptational aspects of it but just like
as a story unto itself it's fun it's
enjoyable the characters are lovable
there's a good sense of tension it's got
good atmosphere very few locations
ultimately but it utilizes them
incredibly well it's got a very talented
cast it's just well made
and I hope that you will share your
thoughts on it as well and also whatever
you think about what I've said for it as
an adaptation
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share and subscribe those all help me
out pardon the fact that I've probably
got sweat above my upper lip we're
actually in the middle of a heat wave
and I uh put on a jacket I debated not
having it but I'm like the the look
doesn't doesn't quite read without it so
here we are I am a sweaty mess
but uh don't don't worry about that
don't pay attention to that what I
really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes joined
in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen auntie
kate808 Becky Sparks pranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scravid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tears but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
foreign
[Music]